[music playing]
In July some of you may know
I went on my honeymoon to Iceland -- It was awesome.
Picked up a an Appalachian dulcimer. It's an American instrument.
Its similar to a traditional Icelandic one as well.
But I finally got a bow for it too which is fun --
you see
you can pluck it... [instrument plucking]
and you can also bow it.
You get a different sound completely.
Sounds real medieval yee
know.
[Strange noises]
I'm not good at playing it. I'm not sure what you were expecting, but it's cool.
So one of my friends reached out to me last night
asking if I'd be interested in having a visit from the team behind character animator --
which ships with After Effects
now character animator is a set of tools meant for basically doing your own cartoons.
and you can do cool things like record your face with a webcam
and have that basically do motion capture and apply it to a cartoon face.
So it's got a lot of really interesting tools.
They're going to give us a little demonstration
and we're going to do a little bit of learnin'
today.
It's like a live action tutorial -- right in front of you.
[chuckles]
I was one of the cofounders of CoSA back in 1990...
where we ended up creating After Effects.
the team since 97 that handbook I've
been on FX
since cuz it back in 92 93 Jeff Holmes
all started with After Effects about 10
so character animator lets you take your photoshop
artwork and bring it to life by tracking
your face and mapping what you do with
Yah I havent messed with it much but...
It looks really sweet, so
in the after effects file menu you can watch character directly or you can watch character animation or just run
it straight why don't you do the demo
okay wow that's perfect so how's he turn
on the camera right there so yeah so
he's gonna use gonna be tracking your
eyebrows your blinking your mouth you
got that's three different shapes right
now the open mouth for surprised if you
smile a smile a little bit and if i zoom
in here you'll see the tracking dots so
that that's all the that's everything is
being tracked we turn on the microphone
oh cool so his mouth moves to the sounds
on making that's really it lost that's
really fast
I'm a because it doesn't over sorry it's
listening and it's figuring out which of
61 different phonemes for singing hmm
and now on the fly then mapping that to
one of eleven different visions the
mouth shapes so if I make my guess
oh wow ah II that's pretty cool
all right you can never point the red
button there there we go all right I'm
inventing a new identity for myself no
one will ever be able to tell that
there's actually a real human being
behind this facade so we just recorded
your head movement your voice the
lip-sync and if you just hit spacebar
alright I'm inventing a new identity for
myself no one will ever be able to tell
that there's actually a real human being
behind this facade and you can then do
multiple recordings and blend them to
the dragger lets me move the hands
around she's got to audible points on
the hands alright I'm inventing a new
identity for myself no one will ever be
able to tell but there's actually a real
human being and I'll beep the dragon on
a record
alright I'm inventing a new identity for
myself no one will ever be able to tell
that there's actually a real human being
kindness asad okay now I talk about my
hands okay
I mean I started actually reporting some
pretty cool stuff this weekend trying to
like I got really like Viking metal and
that's cool but like I'm not a Viking
and I don't understand the Viking
culture as well as like people from you
know Scandinavia do so anything I try
and do musically is just kind of like a
thing in this style so I'm kind of doing
with it more like a Western vibe to my
metal these days because most Americans
kind of grow up a lot more familiar with
like West you know gets it the West is a
very American thing and not a lot of
people do Western metal so I'm like
trying to do a little bit of that kind
of vibe here but so I don't know this is
like with the dulcimer and everything
it's kind of cool though
it's gonna need
it's not Western me right it's cool and
then it's a little froggy like this you
know it's like
can you hear this in the background
so I mean look all right we're gonna
turn you this in my life hell no dude
this is just me for fun man
I just do this on in my free time but
I'm getting a super hardcore in the
recording I got a seven string guitar
and I got a new COO stick they're all
stopgaps you know it's like what's the
cheapest instrument I can possibly get
right now so I can play music I'm
selling off a lot of my old stuff
getting some updated gear and uh uh to
record my school music it's very it's a
very very good feeling to get back into
recording music because it's something I
like a lot you've been making sports for
videos it's like you're not really just
you're not just making music you know
you're dirtier you're making something
that goes with something that's already
created you know it's not as the music
doesn't become a standalone pieces it's
still a soundtrack so it's nice having
uh some music that is that just exists
for listening that's it oh hey look at
this it's our holiday t-shirt or a
sweatshirt if you want that if you're
not in Australia today is the final date
you have to get these things before
there never be a little game you can
have her on the holidays next year in
here after that get them before they're
out forever
st